fans of The Wizarding World have
frequently stated just how important the
game's music will be and it certainly
seems like the developers at Avalanche
have taken that to heart the music and
video that you're about to see and hear
is Overture to the unwritten this video
directed by WB Games avalanche's
marketing manager Eric Martin features a
unique medley of music from Hogwarts
Legacy and if any of you out there had
Hogwarts legacy's music as one of your
top concerns it's time to cross it off
your list now this will be my reaction
to the music that we hear so just be
prepared you're going to hear me talking
as well it almost feels wrong to be
talking over this music so make sure you
guys go and listen to the full video
uninterrupted on the Hogwarts sexy
Channel because here I will be giving
you my reactions throughout the piece
the medley and scenes that they have
prepared in this music video are just
downright stunning let's take a listen
together
foreign
[Music]
it starts
I mean this just instantly feels
familiar instantly familiar and yet
somehow different
love the scene that they chose right
here
oh now that
oh you can you can hear you can hear the
hint
of hedwig's theme right there
[Music]
there it is again like you you know
where you are
you know exactly where you are
and yet it also feels fresh and new it's
amazing
okay shifting
it's almost sounds like Zelda like a
little bit of a serious song there
[Music]
just something about
seeing it performed live too hearing it
perform live
[Music]
oh somebody
's up to something with this one
like sneaking around maybe
[Music]
oh that that whimsical
that that bit of whimsical that is so
important for Harry Potter
hear that right there
[Music]
something a little bit more mysterious
now
also a very important
[Music]
very important piece of the Harry Potter
series that mystery that Whimsical and
then the darkness as well right right we
got to get the darkness
okay this one's a little bit more
triumphant also an important part
[Music]
yes
oh so good
this is like you know we're going on our
journey trying to save the day here
[Music]
triumphant man I love it
[Music]
oh that's a
another shot there and it looks like
dude our character has on the school
robes in that one
it's interesting
oh dude here here's the darkness
we we called it it had to be there right
had to be there
and then of course they're gonna show
from Sebastian's Dark Legacy of course
they are
oh my goodness
oh just like a feeling of of dread right
there
I'm scared
yeah we're definitely in trouble right
here trying to get out of a bad
situation
There's Hope right oh this is this is
the hope now coming through
[Music]
oh that is gorgeous man
is that like the map
some kind of ancient magic going on
there
[Music]
[Applause]
dude this I have literal chills right
now literal chills listening to this
I mean how can how can you not if you're
a fan of this world
oh my goodness man
they've nailed it
oh we're not done yet though we're not
done yet
oh
man
just just this immense feeling of loss
right now from that
oh yeah we've just gotten bad news some
something
bad has happened here
oh but we've gotta we've gotta pick
ourselves up right
oh what a shot
oh it ends on that note too
no way
it ends on that note
oh my goodness okay you guys I'm gonna
be honest with you that was actually
like the third time that I've listened
to that at this point that was the first
time that I really had a chance to sit
down quietly though I mean when they
first posted it today I was I was
working and so I just tried to listen to
it really quick just so I could hear it
and of course I thought it sounded
wonderful but actually setting aside
some time right now in my office alone
lights out oh my goodness man like that
last little section there of the medley
just hit me completely different yeah I
who man some people were asking is there
going to be death in this game I think
so or loss like just the sense of loss
we are going to lose something even even
if it's not a character even if someone
doesn't die which man it really feels
like that to me but they hit on
everything there and I know that's just
a very short piece a medley as Chandler
wood described it for over five minutes
I know the music was such a big concern
for so many of you out there me too too
me too because the series is just known
for its iconic music at this point I
mean you hear the first just three
seconds of hedwig's theme first one
second I mean and you know what that is
and so obviously we heard a lot in this
it was a medley so we got to hear a lot
of different pieces there but I think
this has all the makings of just being
an absolutely incredible soundtrack
which by the way they've also put it on
Apple music and Spotify I assume at some
point we're gonna be able to purchase
this full soundtrack of the game but wow
there were some other things I wanted to
discuss in this video but honestly this
one is just so emotional I mean powerful
what's the right word for it I don't
know man like the power of music you
guys it's just incredible it really is I
mean the fact that we felt so much and I
assuming many of you out there listening
to it feel so much without even a single
word spoken It's amazing And the fact
that I just instantly felt like I was
back in the Wizarding World yet also at
the same time there's this air of
mystery there's this air of wait wait
this is familiar but different I've been
here before but things have changed it's
incredible that they were able to pull
that off just in music if you guys are
new here they actually just released
some more information on the Hogwarts
like the professors four of them
specifically and I have a full video
breaking that down on the right side of
your screen check it out there now as
always thank you all so much for
watching I'll talk to you again soon